moins de 24 heures après la mort d'un
jeune homme de 17 ans tué d'une balle
dans le thorax devant cet immeuble
la police a interpellé un homme de 23
ans connu de la justice pour des faits
de violence et d affaires de stupéfiants
l' enquête pour identifier le tueur
présumé aura donc été rapide
elle a été facilitée par
l'interpellation désir soir d'une
première personne présente dans la
voiture qui a transporté le tueur
présumé devant l'immeuble
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
la victime aurait eu un différend dont
la nature n'a pas été précisée avec le
meurtrier présumé
hier soir les rares il représente
faisait part de leur inquiétude est un
premier méfie avant m'en donnais mes
pieds volé puis sortir moi car depuis
novembre planoise vite au rythme des
fusillades avec pour enjeu le contrôle
de territoires pour le trafic de drogue
plus de dix jeunes gens ont été blessés
début mars un jeune homme de 23 ans
avait été tué après une course-poursuite
près du centre ville
son passager grièvement blessé les deux
mois de confinement ont été plutôt calme
à planoise
mais il n'aura pas fallu longtemps pour
que reprenne ces événements graves
autour du trafic de drogue risques
sanitaires liés aux coronavirus d'un
côté peur pour leur sécurité physique de
l'autre comme une double peine pour les
habitants de ce quartier sensible